Soon the Arrowverse will be missing its namesake
show, as The CW's Arrow will end after eight
seasons with a final ten-episode run.
The other Arrowverse shows will continue,
at least for now.
But here's why the flagship show is really
ending.
Ratings seem to have played a role in Arrow's
cancellation, but they probably weren't the
definitive factor.
Viewership numbers have dropped for a few
years, and in 2017 the show was shifted to
Thursday in the hopes it would get some castoffs
from Supernatural's superior ratings.
Unfortunately, it instead suffered a 14 percent
ratings decline.
Viewership dropped off again in 2018, at which
point the question on most fans' minds may
have been why it wasn't already canceled.
A couple days after the announcement that
Arrow would end, ScreenRant reported that
while the show continued to lose viewers in
2019, things weren't completely bleak.
In fact, the site reported that statistics
they received from an analytics firm showed
Arrow as the second most successful of CW's
four Arrowverse series at the time of its
cancellation, coming behind only The Flash.
So while flagging ratings may have contributed
to the end, one would assume that Supergirl
and Legends of Tomorrow would also be cut
if that were the only factor.
The term "superhero fatigue" has been thrown
around for a few years now, with people understandably
wondering exactly when the public is going
to grow tired of caped crusaders.
Arrow may be the victim of a CW-specific version
of this phenomenon.
Along with all the Arrowverse shows, the network
also airs Black Lightning, it will soon air
Batwoman, and there continue to be rumblings
about Superman getting his own CW entry.
The Arrowverse was already crowded, and it's
getting more crowded every year.
One of the factors of the decision to end
Arrow may be that there simply isn't enough
room for it.
The timing of the cancellation makes this
possibility more likely considering Batwoman's
pending arrival.
Of all the Arrowverse series, Arrow is usually
the grittiest.
And Batwoman may need to inherit that title
in order to thrive.
Another possible reason for Arrow's finale
is that it's a perfect time to end it.
The Arrowverse is known for its annual crossover
events.
The 2018 edition, entitled "Elseworlds," featured
a seemingly godlike being called The Monitor
who said he was preparing Earth-1 for something
cataclysmic.
"This world will be doomed, like all the others."
Then the crossover ended with a tease for
the following year's event, which will be
called "Crisis On Infinite Earths."
That's also the name of a classic 1985 comics
story that might be the most important DC
Comics crossover of all time.
It changed the publisher's entire fictional
landscape, bringing together disparate narratives
and completely wiping out others.
The event was also noteworthy for some prominent
character deaths, which is where Arrow may
come in.
Since the final season will only be 10 episodes,
the finale will probably air close to the
crossover.
Considering the timing, it seems like a good
bet that whatever narrative choices are made
to wrap up the story of Oliver Queen, possibly
including a heroic death, they'll have a whole
lot to do with the events of "Crisis."
Perhaps we shouldn't be asking why Arrow is
ending, but instead why it's even lasted this
long.
Oliver Queen has walked over the same ground
again and again, literally and figuratively.
There have been hours and hours of flashbacks
to the Island of Lian Yu [lee-ANN YOO] where
he was "stranded."
Meanwhile in the present, he and his Team
Arrow buddies have gone back to the island
so often that it's a little confusing why
they don't just build a summer home there.
There have also been countless times when
characters have died and then somehow come
back, or sworn off the crime-fighting game
only to quickly return to it.
But worse than the repetitive plot points
is the ongoing, unconvincing struggle with
Oliver's darker self.
His inner struggle seems to say that he is
both Hannibal Lecter and the only person who
can solve the world's problems.
It's a dead horse that the Arrow creative
team finally needs to stop beating.
Moving on
According to the show's star Stephen Amell,
the biggest determining factor for ending
Arrow was Green Arrow himself.
Shortly after the announcement that the show's
eighth season would be its last, Amell posted
a Facebook video to let fans know what had
happened.
He revealed that he'd approached producer
Greg Berlanti at the end of the sixth season,
expressing his wish for season seven to be
the last.
"I've always been a fan of television shows
that not only don't overstay their welcome,
but end in a manner that really packs a punch."
Fittingly, considering his character has grown
to be much more of a family man over the years,
Amell told viewers that the changes in his
own life behind the camera greatly informed
his desire for Arrow to conclude.
Like the character he plays, he's become a
husband and a father himself, and it's understandably
been a significant change in his life.
Flashbacks have been one of Arrow's hallmarks
since its first season.
But the show switched things up starting in
Season 7, as the premiere ended with a flash-forward
set 20 years in the future with Oliver's grown
son William meeting an older Roy Harper.
Over the course of the season, a story has
been unfolding in the flash-forwards about
a time when "vigilante" has become a dirty
word.
By going forward, Arrow has painted itself
into a corner.
Unless there is some sort of time-traveling
salvation, everyone watching the show knows
how the future looks for its characters, and
it's not good.
As one review for CinemaBlend put it, the
flash-forwards potentially took away any reason
to keep watching.
From that perspective, it's best for Arrow
to wrap up quickly before things get any worse.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.